hey what's up everybody happy 2024 it's
February already but it's a new year
nonetheless a year full of exciting New
Opportunities a year of new doors to
open some of you are just beginning your
creative Journey this year and others
are adding new knowledge to their career
but each and every one of us started our
3D Journey for one reason and that is to
play to create to have fun so let's take
February to do just that together so
it's my pleasure to introduce to you the
Eternal Ascent 3D community challenge
that's right this month I am challenging
you to put your unique Twist on this
provided barebones template and in the
end I'll combine each and every one of
our submissions to create a mega all
renders Montage if you follow the rules
and a handcrafted top 100 Montage
complete with original music by the man
who scored alternate realities and
moving meditations that's right the very
talented feverkin will be joining us
once again then on March 9th live on
stream I'll be joined by gu judge Gavin
Shapiro to reveal the top 100 to the
world and announce the top five artists
as the Eternal Ascent 3D Community
challenge Champions Gavin is a digital
wizard known for his god tier looping
Creations honestly they're insane go
check out his Instagram they're all
super addicting and we have teamed up to
create this template file together just
for you guys I pride these challenges on
being fun and if you've seen them around
and thought oh man I always wanted to
join one of those well now is the time
Scott I'm looking at you this is your
time you got this this challenge is a
real fun way to let your imagination
soore and at the end of it all you'll
walk away with new friends and art that
you're proud of and if that's not reason
enough to embark on this 3D Quest
together then check this out through
February Jenga effects is opening up
their entire Suite to you guys that
means free Ember genen and free geogen
for all it'll definitely come in handy
when filling out your vast environment
go check it out in the description when
you get get started and guys there is a
massive pull of prizes for the artists
who want to go for gold this B who want
to hunker down who want to buckle up and
charge full stee ahead and if that
sounds like you then listen up if your
art comes in the fourth or fifth place
spot I am happy to announce that XP pen
is joining the roster and hooking you
guys up with their Deco Pro Gen 2 tablet
and you get to choose the size that best
fits your setup The Deco Pro Series
tablets can be wired or Wireless they
run out a 10-hour charge and ship with a
pen of course pen accessories and an X
remote control to customize your
physical and digital workflow they're
comfortable they got a super satisfying
paper-like texture to them and are
hailed as being the most accurate
tablets out there with 16,000 levels of
pen pressure goodness now I take my
wrist Health seriously and using a
tablet versus a mouse helps us artists
maintain RIS longevity so it's a joy to
have XP pen joining us on this one and
if you thought I was done with the
fourth and fifth place prizes welcome to
the channel it's good to see you guys
you're also getting a oneyear Maxon one
subscription complete with Cinema 4D and
the red shift render engine of course
but also zbrush the industry standard
for digital sculpting as well as the
entire red giant effect Suite which I
use all the time when comping in After
Effects or editing in D Vinci resolve to
add say realistic VHS effects camera
Shake film grain and more and Maxon one
also ships with forger for modeling and
sculpting on your iPad fourth and fifth
place artists also get a one-year
grayscale gorilla Plus Membership whose
assets and tools are now available
wherever you guys do 3D they're known
for the highest quality assets built for
close-ups product rendering and Beyond
with a library of 4,000 plus textures
materials and models also you guys can
sign up for a free Grace scale gorilla
Plus account to get instant access to
their free assets which you can use to
light and texture your art next up is D
Jango effects yes they're giving you
their Suite free for the month but for
fourth and fifth they're throwing you a
permanent Indie license for the Jenga
effects Suite which includes all their
software meaning free Ember genen for
Life free geogen their new terrain
generator and all future releases for
life with one year of Maintenance I
might add fourth and fifth place are
also getting a one-year roko Vision
subscription for suitless motion capture
using not one but two cameras for a
higher Fidelity capture if you're
capturing suitless this is the way to go
and finally CFT the Turkish design brand
is throwing you 200 bucks toward
anything on their site theyve become a
challenge staple at this point and I've
loved everything that they've sent my
way Turkish textiles are known as world
class and the calf designs are too it's
an honor to have you guys on board again
all right y'all that was just fourth and
fifth we're just getting to third place
all right so if you come in third you're
getting literally everything I just
mentioned but instead of a deco Pro
tablet XP pen is up grading you to their
14in color accurate artist Pro display
complete with the X remote a 1610 1920 x
1200 display and a builtin kickstand to
make illustration easy on the eyes and
the wrists and Roco is going to top
things off by throwing in their head rig
for facial motion capture good head rigs
are hard to come by and this one is no
exception cuz they're set up to
counterweight your phone they're padded
in all the right places and fully adjust
to any head shape whether you got a cone
head or look like this guy from needle
juice but look if your art comes in
second place you're getting something
special because on top of every prize
from third I am happy to announce that
HTC Vive creators of the Vive VR
headsets are also joining the roster to
set you up with their latest their
greatest that's right you're getting
their allnew Vive XR Elite headset
offering all-in-one XR and wireless PC
VR this headset offers High Fidelity
untethered VR Gaming experiences as well
as as tools to expand your 3D art you
can design in mixed reality with their
highres full color pass through cameras
and bring virtual objects into your
physical space but yo they're also
sending you five of their brand new
Ultimate trackers for up to 8 point full
body VR tracking that means your hands
your feet your elbows knees hips and
head are all accurately mapped in
virtual reality to make gaming and VR
chat much more immersive these full body
trackers are self-tracking and actually
don't require base stations either and
to top it off they're also hooking you
up with their full face tracker to
capture your eyes and mouth during VR
chat sessions huge shout outs to HTC for
joining us on this challenge but y'all
know we ain't done with second right cuz
the prize pool wouldn't be complete
without roko throwing in some smart
gloves to make manual hand and finger
tracking a thing of the past and you
don't need a motion capture suit to use
them but I never record map without them
I love these things and I know you will
too and finally to top off the second
place prize pot XP pen is upgrading you
once again to their 16in color accurate
2560 x600 resolution artist Pro
display but ladies and gentlemen we've
made it all the way to first place it's
a difficult place to land but the prizes
get even better because on top of the
year-long subscriptions for Maxon one
gray skill gorilla plus and Roco Vision
the permanent Indie license for janga
suite and the $200 C prize where Coco is
throwing in a little something extra
it's a piece of Hardware that will
change the game of the cameralist map
suit industry I'm talking about the coil
or Coco's topper to their motion capture
Arsenal you place the coil somewhere in
your motion capture vicinity and it
communicates with the suit acting as a
ground truth providing acute accuracy to
your map data and you'll be among one of
the first to get your hands on one oh
and they're also throwing in an entire
full performance capture bundle bundle
complete with a smart suit Pro 2 smart
gloves and a headset for facial capture
but it ain't over yet because XP pen is
going all the way and maxing you out
with their top-of-the-line 24in 2K color
accurate pen display to make all your
illustration dreams come true and
finally like actually finally this is
the last first place prize you're flying
out to hang out with me this September
at camp mograph in Chicago they're also
setting up camp in Australia too for
those artists on that side of the world
but Camp mograph is probably the best 3D
artist Convention of all time because
instead of a loud show floor and flashy
lights you are surrounded by Serene
natural beauty instead of marketing in
salespeople there's lifelong friendships
to be made and instead of crowded panels
there's intimate workshops led by some
of your favorite 3D artists I might also
be teaching some yoga classes we'll see
we'll see the Camp counselors are saving
you a spot and the very good people at
Maxon are flying you out so it is all
expenses paid and you know what getting
into the top 100 Montage after the
challenge is all said and done is no
easy feat so I wanted to give you guys
just a little something extra first C
has given away 100 t-shirts for this
Challenge and letting each of the top
100 artists walk away with any t-shirt
they want from their wide selection of
designs second XP pen is hooking you up
with 25% off toward any of their X3 Pro
Series products on their site and
finally D Jango effects is giving the
top 100 artists an extra 2 months of
that glorious Jenga effects Suite I want
to offer a deep and heartfelt thank you
to the 3D challenge sponsors Maxon XP
pen HTC Roco D Jenga effects grayscale
gorilla camp mograph and Cal for helping
make these challenges as epic as they
are I couldn't do this without you guys
and with that it's time to have some fun
your mission if you choose to accept is
to download the project files below
inside you'll find your template file
prepared in the program of your choice
and as always we like to keep the rules
simple all you got to do is replace the
character with your own incorporate the
stairs into your render maintaining its
visual weight that means up and to the
right like you see here and don't touch
the camera that's it other than that the
challenge is to create to build whatever
you'd like in one month's time our home
base for these challenges is on my free
Discord server where you'll find a
helpful list of challenge specific FAQs
guidelines for best practices Monday
meetups to feature your Works in
progress and best of all a massive
community of passionate artists to learn
and grow with during this Challenge and
Beyond the deadline is Sunday March 3rd
at 11:59 p.m. I'll say it again Sunday
March 3rd 11:59 p.m. PST which gives you
exactly 1 month to create from there
I'll pick the top 100 pull the five
winners with Gavin and we'll see you
guys for the live top 100 reveal on
Saturday March 9th at 10:45 a.m. PST but
guess what I am live streaming right now
this very second that is right click on
over let's do this I'll get you guys
started we'll dive in together we'll
take a look at everything inside we'll
get you guys started I'll answer any
questions you have I'll walk you through
the Discord server how to get started on
that it'll be easy we'll make it real
fun I'll see you guys soon peace